[Music]
all the pieces
you know it's funny you say that
actually it's funny you say that
because in my discord yesterday this got
posted
and it was like this is going to be
cjm's plan for the event
right and i was like what what is this
image so like i pulled it up and i was
like well
uh you know this is a powerful this is
my
plan of attack i've got one plan and one
plan alone
you think you can stop me i'm gonna show
up punch everybody to
death by the way working from home so
you know business up top
party down low right i'm wearing gym
shorts here full disclosure
this is connor the guy with the is it
fair to say you have the sexiest voice
in a voice in anime
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you thank you jesus
wait what i drive
yes i have oh up ah
good game gone i can't believe god
nearly threw at the end that king
that king moved i'm pretty sure
my blind grandma wouldn't make that king
move god
what was that move i don't need shady
tactics
i don't need underhanded ploys what i
need
is the loyalty to my lineage
to the people who brought me from the
ground up
who believed in me when i didn't even
believe in myself jt
today i'm making you i'm making you
proud
it seems i've made a great error in
judgment
i really want to see what ollie's
thinking here and what she's calculating
i hope that she sees the check
but let's see
can i can i can i just say can i just
call out connor right now because i
think i know what he's watching
i know he's watching he tried definitely
watching he titled his stream
watching ollie play chess what about me
dude
i thought we were friends i've slept on
your floor man
and uh that was week one and now we are
in week two
this is actually the last day of
tournament arc ii
i am so sad to see it end but i'm also
so stoked to see
how it ends jt what's up dude
hey how's it going going good man um
do you feel the same way as i do right
now i'm still in my feelings right now
yeah like
it's why does today have to be the last
thing why can't it just exist why can't
we just do it forever
but there has to be a winner right and
i'm so perplexed i don't know what i
want to win because yesterday was
it had had me in my lack of a better
term
in my back i was so emotional i was like
rusted
she lost but then you're gonna win and
i'm like hey sam
i love you the best pikachu i don't and
then they're gonna face off
and i'm just like oh no and then giga
because he was like kind of being a
villain
and during his games like should i make
him suffer
comes out with a stubble just got out of
bed
gotta delay the match to go to the
bathroom like that's some
that's some villain behavior i don't
know guys who is the protagonist
uh we are going to find out today
because we have two matches
the redemption final between esam
and russet both players have had to
crawl their way
and claw their way back and one of them
will move on to face gigguk
for the championship in the grand final
both of these matches happen today so we
actually take a break
after the redemption final and then we
do the thing
we we finish this thing out we take it
home
the the the cows come home the chickens
come to roost
the the okay i'm done with those all
right so
uh man this has been a
long road and we've already got a fourth
place
winner in sea dog va after he
unfortunately felt
esam in the uh the match yesterday
um esam and russiage are now going to
play not only for
the position the grand final but also
third place uh
for whoever loses this match and
everybody's going to go home with some
cash money first place the winner of
tournament arc 2 is gonna get
four grand that's uh not bad for
a couple weekends of chess second place
third place 1500 bucks going to either
esam or russet here in this first match
uh sea dog va walks out of here with 800
and uh our other players 300 bucks a
piece so everybody gets something
the format of the tournament it's hard
to believe this is the last time i'm
going to read this card
uh we just talked about the bracket but
let's talk about the games 10 minutes on
each player's clock
they will also get a five seconds added
to
their clock after every move and they're
going to play at best of three match so
first to two points wins their pairing
if they tie after three games they will
go into a tiebreaker
which is only three minutes on the clock
and no increment per move so
they gotta move quickly um
what else is there to say i mean maybe
we could talk about the players
e sam represented by panda
esports organization he is the number
one
pikachu in smash ultimate for the last
11 years and
uh definitely one of the strongest
players
in the tournament maybe even the most
prepared having played on chess.com as a
premium member for over a year
before being invited to the event he is
going to face rustic who
returns from tournament arc one he uh
does some amazing amazing content on
youtube
you definitely need to go on youtube
find rustage
if you're a fan of anime and rap he
brings both of those things together
and uh the dude has got man he's got
lyrics
like seriously good stuff and the winner
between their match will face gigguk in
the grand final
uh gigguk has been like just a big
presence
in anime and otaku content on youtube
for years now and is a co-host of the
trash taste
podcast i think they just crossed a
million subscribers
uh just in the last few they they
finished also i believe their 50th
episode
make sure you check out trash taste on
youtube
and now we've introduced the players
um i i want to actually
take this opportunity it feels wrong but
it feels justified
in a way to shamelessly plug ourselves
jt
we want people to know that we both also
have youtube channels
that they should check out right it's
fair
i think it's fair okay okay you start
me no you
okay fine i'll go first so if you are
interested in learning how to stream
whether it's chess or anything else
you can check out my channel on youtube
youtube.com aaron hawaii
and uh you'll find tutorials teaching
you how
to start streaming and if you already
stream how to make it even more awesome
i also talk a little bit about the the
climate of
streaming and content creation in terms
of whether or not it's viable as a way
to
make some extra income and uh and that's
it that's me
jt your turn tell us what you do
i mostly post educational chess content
and so the lessons that
you saw me do on stream with some of the
content creators i posted them
on youtube as well as other lessons so
yeah that's what i do nothing's special
but i think it's very informative
for those who want to get into chats and
want to get stronger
quickly yeah i would say jt is probably
like one of the best coaches that i have
just watched and seen do his thing live
on twitch and also on youtube so
go check us out and uh we will be right
back because in about
four minutes the games will start
rustage
versus esam for a spot in the grand
final we'll see you guys in just a sec
okay okay
okay okay okay
small delay there's a small delay
uh ah
well before before i inevitably lose
this game i just want to say thank you
to everyone
for supporting me and thank you to
connor for having me on
and inviting me again to this thing it
has been a lot of fun even though i know
that
i am i've really struggled these last
few games and stuff i'm gonna just try
my best
to not blunder
and just play like a solid game and then
after this is over i can get back to
work because i've really fallen behind
on work
because i've been spending a lot of
effort just trying to do semi decently
in this thing
um but yeah i know i wasn't like
a favorite to win a lot of my games and
stuff obviously but i
i appreciate the support that people
have given me over the course of these
and
and i just think everyone's been really
nice and supportive and
it's been it's been good it's been great
and i'll do
i'll do my best i'll do my best
i'll play slower i think i'd rather just
lose on time but play a solid game
then just like blunder a bunch because
i'm stressing out
but yeah also happy birthday connor
i don't know if he's i don't even know
if i'm on the stream right now
um but happy birthday connor if he's
listening
uh
oh so i'm releasing an album soon
uh i think um
esam said he was doing puzzles right out
to this
i should just be doing puzzles right now
that maybe that's the strategy
you've gotta you just gotta puzzle away
um
i feel like puzzles don't train me quite
like because
in a puzzle you know there's a set
solution but when you're
playing a game of chess every move you
don't actually know there's a set
solution to the move
that you're the the thing right
um
so i feel like it i don't know i don't
know if it's actually really helpful for
me
all right the time is here dude it's uh
research versus ese i'm probably gonna
start like 30 seconds or so
um but yeah in some cases
i would say that the stakes are higher
here
than maybe even in the grand final
because
uh i i don't know it just that feels
that feels accurate to me
because one of these guys goes home with
the third place prize and the other one
gets an opportunity you know
right right it's a chance at that
not only the prize money but also the
title
saying hey i won tournament arc 2. yeah
yeah and and maybe maybe for e sam
the stakes are even higher because if he
won tournament arc he would have done it
having faced more opponents and beaten
them than anyone else to get there
so anywho games are underway and wow
they're
blitzing out moves really fast i feel
like they
both i don't know that we would see this
unless they both prepared
for today yeah i think they definitely
both prepared something because i know
russia's prepares for his opponents
and isam is playing the same system that
he was playing in the previous game so
i'm wondering
what's happening here i would love to
look into e7 see what he's thinking yeah
and maybe he thinks why not right it's
been working so far
why change it
patented you saying music and beatboxing
[Music]
oh that did not work out for him
i didn't notice he had an extra defender
oh wow this is brutal
it's playing a little bit too fast here
[Music]
holy moly
he's trying to figure out how to work
himself out of a tough situation
and let's see oh wrestage actually gives
him the opportunity
to correct it but man i i don't know
that i would have expected this
i wouldn't have expected esam to make a
mistake like that so early in the game
and
rustage like dude he's doing his thing i
wonder if it's prep or if it's just
patience you know what i think is
happening i think
russ is prepared and i think isam is
just saying hey
um i'm already in my match with giga
get me there right and he's not taking
the
maybe he's not taking the tournament one
game at a time like you should right you
have to focus on
every single game instead of thinking
about the whole game
uh and the whole tournament you got to
say i'm playing this one game and i have
to do my best in this one game first
before i can think about anything else
yeah i don't know i mean i don't think
he's
maybe not giving the same respect that
he was giving to the gig because
here he's just playing fast and he made
a blunder extremely quickly
now luckily um rostage didn't take full
advantage of that blunder
but isam is such a strong player that he
shouldn't be making these blunders
right out of the opening
i mean let's listen into the rustage and
see what
what's happening what's going through
his brain because maybe this is part of
his set play
and what he wants to do actually
okay
should i develop my knight
i could do this still he takes there i
put my queen there i'm threatening this
but
or threatening a bunch of stuff here i
could also push the pawn up
as well uh to protect the um
bishop and kind of solidify its position
is there any issues with that um
is this queen threatening anything new i
think that's an okay move
i think maybe just okay i actually like
the trade of the bishops better
what do you think mm-hmm yeah i
i like bishop h6 and this phrase it's
like the normal plan and these kind of
openings
even now just bishop h6 right and the
idea
could be like f3 and g4 at some point to
try to break open this king side and
moving the stroke over yeah and the
difference now is that since esam has
pushed the pawn
the queen could take that bishop with
kind of like infiltration now the queen
is in your house
even scarier for esam than before
so maybe rustage delaying this plan
and reacting after h5 makes this
stronger than it was earlier
yeah i mean i think a little bit earlier
it was more effective because the idea
would be that the queen is on h6 right
and the pawns here and then we can push
h5 so when we take with
uh this pawn this rook will be healthy
right that's a common idea in these kind
of fiance openings
by the way encounter just means like
this structure the pawns like this and
and the bishop on the span yeah whereas
before
whereas now based on what you were
saying you have to make multiple moves
to then capitalize
you know you gotta like you said push f3
g4 trade some stuff and like it takes a
little bit longer
well here actually i think esam made a
slight error
because we can do that much faster now
with
bishop captures king captures
and then foreign wow
look at that that is spicy and let's see
esam uh measuring how this is gonna work
out for him he's actually looking at
some differences
[Music]
oh interesting e sam was actually
looking at the queen
pinning the knight on d4 after the
bishops trade but i
don't know if that's really what he's
gonna have to worry about
and go here
[Music]
and this to this went upon
also eggs eggs
[Music]
eggs
like this because it depends like he
kind of has to take here
he's completely right about that he he's
kind of forced to take to keep the
advantage
[Music]
yeah and i want to see how russiage
battles with this decision now
this to support it or
i might i could just threaten his queen
in this move
oh i could retreat my uh bishop here
there's a way i can trap his
sneaky boy oh man i i'm worried russet
is losing the plot here because i think
he
yeah he's done that move because now i
can't push the f pawn up to
threaten him i think i might
uh
because if i do this it moves that out
of the way so i can actually put the
rook there
because he's got to deal with this first
and then i could put the rook here to
protect this pawn
so he won't have that move anymore
which is what he's trying to do on me
wow this could win upon a piece what his
next move is gonna be
okay so oh
um queen trade but i did say
if there was a queen trade i would do it
because then i can't blunder my queen
but what are the consequences of this if
i take this and he takes there
i do get to take the bishop
and then he can't actually do this i'm
gonna queen trade
unfortunately because even if he does
yes he is now down a piece the rook will
take the bishop
but i kind of like that at least rook
taking on d2
defends the fork of knight takes f2
but wrestage definitely didn't realize
that at the end of that line he was
going to lose that bishop
and that's ultimately i think the
consequence of not taking the bishop
early on i mean that was kind of the
plan of sending the bishop over there in
the first place to trade them
and uh you have to remember your plans
like you you can't you can't forget
if you say if they do that i will do
this then when the time comes
unless something is significantly
changed about the position
you should do what you set out to do
that's exactly true um a lot of people
forget their plans they're like oh but
now this moves available remember why
you played that move
originally just go ahead i'll try to
follow your plan if
if possible obviously if this checkmate
don't follow your plan
checkmate them but you should see that
in your calculation as well
yeah but here it's it's really
interesting
i mean these two pieces are not out yet
and i would suggest maybe something like
knight g5 maybe like f3 you know try to
get this bishop maybe and like trying to
get the knights of d5
okay they're close okay right right i
should just call out more moves right
the prophet prophet exactly i don't know
if donya will let you have that nickname
but i'm giving it to you at least for
now
got it okay yeah and that's a good move
too i like that knight e5 which
threatens
knight f6 check taking the rip
um and also threatening maybe c7 as well
so it depends on where this bishop goes
because we could have a situation where
something like this happens and then
knight a6 to defend it and then f3
oh here i would i would 100 take
yeah because then you definitely get the
square for your knight
oh yeah and oh and that's scary after f3
where does your knight go
has to go to h6 right the the idea here
would be
to play um takes rook
takes back after the knight takes and
then knight d5 is a really strong square
and the idea is you can't take on e4
with the rook in that line because then
we have f3
working the pieces right and also
let's say you try to kick the knight
with c6 well then knight c7
you get the rook in the corner right
exactly
wow wow wow wow lots of potential in
this position for both players
let's listen into esam and see how he
feels about the scenario which is then
i'm activating my rook
like activating activating it uh he
still doesn't really have a weight
in like this is good i guess but like
it's not
great this is always in fear of hanging
i mean unless he wants to
push it in which case i just like
have offensive pressure and i can like
move it around
support this push up should really move
my knight
and any of these pawns oh no no
no no no no no no no don't do that don't
do that
how do i undo that i guess it was
diagonal so
nothing would have been possible there
but i don't i didn't mean
[Music]
and again might be a situation where
rustage forgets what the plan was
you went there for a reason to take the
bishop probably
right
oh i he's looking at that move and i'm
not liking that move at all let's see if
he plays it does he play it
he does wow what is going on both of
these
it's another the easiest idea that i see
on the board
would honestly be just to play knight b5
immediately and say hey
i'm threatening this i'm threatening
this what are you actually doing
right that's a free pawn and
we might be getting back into this right
that's uh
seven pawns versus seven pawns so
maybe we get a pawn for a piece and
maybe
can hold a draw especially since this
rook can get active so quickly
yeah but i don't i don't know also look
at the difference on the clock
russet has two and a half minutes to
esam six
and maybe that's part of it too sticking
to your plan might have made you move
faster
and now because you back out all those
plans you have to form new plans
and that takes time let's listen in
as well as threatening that square and
he he can only really defend either one
of those
with with the rook so he kind of has to
decide
which one he wants to defend
alternatively he does have a night move
he says
that's still um that's still good though
no it's not
he just takes it the night
uh damn
the hanging pawn looks like it might be
my only move here and at least i
it creates a threat so i'm going to do
it anyway okay buddy
by the knight too why i i like the rook
take as well
it's nice nice oh but it undefends this
point but
it undefends that point
he's just gonna make this move now
oh my gosh what a silly little fella i
am
what a silly little goofy guy what a
silly little fella
that's an almost guaranteed move i feel
well i've got to move the rook
that's bad because of that i can't i
just can't do that
uh it's just a pawn for a pawn it was a
porn trade
you know how things be in this business
probably just
oh actually hold up hold up hold up
there's that move
so i might actually do this nice yes
perfect
and so the reason i said it's not that
big because i did this because
i'm gonna say the idea right now right
so like the idea is all of our pieces
are
actually working oh my oh my there's a
free piece here
he just dropped the bishop he said
just dropped a piece let's see if he
salmon
realizes that he just dropped the piece
he can't defend it
oh i just blundered peace
[Music]
whoops
that's not fun
okay but look rustage has to move
quickly but safely and
yikes maybe he blunted the piece
right too late oh no
you have seven wins uh wins the rook
right back
unfortunately it wins the rooker right
back
um
i think the only move here is to maybe
play something like rock f1
and you know hoping that they
they move somewhere like here and then
we can have this check
hope that that's what we're hopeful for
and maybe at least it's not a rook yeah
but uh you have to see that sequence
first
and that's a hard sequence to see
especially when you have 35 seconds on
the next slide
oh this might be trapped this might be a
trapped fella
that's a really good that's a really
good king move
that way i can threaten something else
of his if i
move um under 10 seconds almost
it's getting there rustage is gonna have
to realize this
i don't think i was gonna win this game
anyway
um
i'm gonna take that just even though
he's gonna take
get something out of it you know
check him there
yep and now these trades are not good
for him
running out of time i did actually miss
click but it's not tragic
it's not like it was a big blonde or
anything
um
[Music]
i could have just done that i don't know
why didn't just do that
that's a stupid move
i mean i'm out of time i can't really
think about my moves anymore
drops another piece and um
is there um
i wonder if there's a way i can
stalemate this though still
love the way he's thinking yes yes
always go for the still means
yeah there might be a way i can still
stalemate this
if i like and esam is gobbling pawns
i'm just moving pieces randomly i
actually got quite a lot of time back
from moving my pieces randomly like that
oh sneaky
yeah that was actually a misclick with
my knight i actually don't know if that
was a move that like meant i lost
lost but oh hold up
and i have a little run whoa he's going
to get queen before me
but i'm still going to get a queen
no no i'm not because he's just gonna
[Music]
now if you don't want to stalemate you
got to remember your abcs always be
checking did you make that one up
just now
i'm just being very very careful
[Music]
all right that's gonna do it pretty
simple pattern that's going to do it
yeah
get your ladder checkmate
and there were a lot of opportunities to
come back for russia
you know calm down i think there's a lot
of torment jitters and nerves and stuff
like that
and honestly issa just played well i
mean i think
he said needs to slow a bit down as well
because there were opportunities that he
could take
to just steal the deal much faster
but overall a good sense of where the
pieces go and
i think high accuracy as well yeah for
such a sharp game
that actually was uh really high quality
from both players
and i'm especially impressed with the
way that rustic played that game
um you know despite the despite the loss
that was uh that was pretty good i think
with better time management
that might have gone a different way and
russage had clear advantages
in a few moments uh which means that
esam is not indestructible
so we are gonna go on a break and when
we come back we will have
game two and uh
yeah we're about to find out if we're
gonna have a game three or game four
five six seven
please all right we'll be right back all
right take care guys see you soon
so good i loved that move best move is
probably just go like there
[Music]
oh it wants to take i guess
but yeah and then this he tried to
tactics me
but i went up a piece because of it
yeah i just completely forgot that that
was protecting them
[Music]
then obviously didn't mate him the most
efficiently
[Music]
but
i was just like i'm not messing with any
wasn't made in one two
i guess it's like this
and then it's promote and i
what's the mate oh this
oh oh it's this
either way i was scared i was just
scared i was just scared
so i look i was like it
like we play super simple we back up i'm
scared
i'm just gonna do the ladder i was just
i don't want to stalemate by accident i
had plenty of time but i was just like i
can
i know how to like i know that that's
good enough
[Music]
okay finding that king watching the end
going straight i trust you
[Music]
yes it's stressful
ontario will guide me though
how do i edit a chess video i have
no idea how like i want to make this a
youtube video because i'm proud of how
i'm doing
and how i'm playing overall but i have
zero clue
how to edit this
[Music]
like oh let me do predictions for
game two
all right speaking of predictions i'm
gonna predict what i think both players
need to do
and you tell me if i'm off base here if
i'm missing something
so i feel like rustic
needs to speed up and esam
maybe needs to slow down because he also
had a lot of time on his clock
towards the end of that game and maybe
i'll annotate a little bit by saying
also russet
needs to trust his instincts and stick
with his plans because they were good
plants
um there's one more thing that isam
needs to do and he needs to
dm me the link for that song it's so
good really need that in my playlist
i'm just like cat jamming in the
background i'm just like yes this is
like the most amazing thing i've ever
seen
and i've heard and just witnessed in my
life so i need it
he said well you'll probably see it in
the recap i need the song
thank you yeah i i actually i can get
with that
i can get with that we'll ask him in the
interview where he gets his music but uh
sounds good we're we got a game in
between
that and uh
that so here comes the game
uh easing with the white pieces now and
uh let's see if both players play as
quickly
in the opening as they did in that other
game and look at this
c6 d5 i think this was also something
that
rustage prepared it looks familiar to me
uh this is actually what um sea dog was
playing
so one of the things that i went over
with sea dog is how to play the caro
khan and how to play the caracon
effectively
which is why i think in the opening he
got a lot of great positions
oh and look at this queen trade esam
castle now having moved the king this is
this is a victory pretty good victory
is winning this he cannot okay he cannot
blunder his queen anymore
rusted yeah
i mean that was his strat in the first
game too
man look at the quality of these moves
by rustage this is this is great i want
to see
where he's going with this that's fair i
think i'll just leave it here though
because it's not immediately being
threatened um
move this here
because actually i can still make this
move okay
i've got to be careful here i don't want
to get trapped
but i'll still move back i think going
here is fine
um i'll just move the pawn up here if he
moves down
so i have a little space for my bishop
and he has to realize he's actually
added another i just feel like
now this feels like a bad move for some
reason
and i wonder why that is because i can
just move
with the um it opens up that i don't
think that's
good um
move this away and he's just gonna take
a move here that's not a too bad
developing move as well
centralize it
you know so pieces belong this is good
this is a good chest so far
yeah i mean there was a potential threat
there if you place the knight on e4
and esam didn't take knight takes f2
would be a fork of the king and the rook
um but i also like this too i think he
realizes that
the trade on d5 is not bad for him
positionally
right right and then there's another
threat here well after obviously
the recapture this pawn is extremely
weak
there goes uh there was a small trek and
here there are two ways to defend
obviously knight c6 are here
also king over is just fine as well
but i think one of these students is a
little bit better because the idea is if
they take on g7 we take with the king
and our king is closer to the center
and our work is going to go on the c
file if they don't notice this
and if they take with knight c6 when we
just take here and play c5
yeah and then you've got some nice pawns
in the center
nice strong position to work from okay
let's see
uh what esam opts to do oh look he's
putting pressure on the pin piece
gotta like that
ep on the pee pee put pressure on the
paw on the pink piece
yes sir only castle that's the phrase
that's catchphrase
[Music]
the castling here is really bad in this
direction
that also means that issan was listening
to my lessons with connor
okay but he does it
anyway
wow so jt e sam thinks that that is a
bad choice
agree or disagree i
i agree i honestly i think king d7 might
have been a
tad bit stronger oh wait wait there's
there's a blunder on the board there's a
blunder on the board whoa whoa whoa what
just happened
this this is attacking here but this is
free
yes it's 3.99 and it's also attacking
here
yeah yeah so take the bishop if you take
the rook i mean it's six for five right
you're you're you're you're sacrificing
two very active pieces for one very
passive piece
and then the next thing is that we're
also attacking c2 the bishop
on f6 and now night captures
makes a lot of sense now yeah now it's
absolutely free for the taking wow
look look at rustage go but does he
see what he's got on the board i'm
certainly this
oh he can just take the pawn that's the
problem
i see i see now
okay his focus seems to be on
kind of the wrong side of the board here
to begin with okay
here the thing is if he takes there i'll
just take here and then i'm threatening
that
so if i move i should just move the rook
uh the rook
going there defends the knight which is
good
and it's protected by the bishop oh i
think he still
kind of thinks that his king is
that the knight is pinned but he castled
out of the pin
right right right now if he takes there
i'll just take with this
i guess that undefends this for a second
but it's not immediately being attacked
by anything unless he does this move
what is going on in this game what is
going on here what is going on here
is interesting because is this being
defended by anything
what happens when i take there oh my
gosh
esam actually made it easier to get the
free piece
right he's like look if you're not gonna
take the free piece that i gave you
i would just hand it right to you
camera again
okay look now restage is doing good here
but
look at the clock again under time less
three minutes less than e sam
there's a lot of good moves here but i
think the best idea is just to trade
down here right like
yep take here let's say king takes the
knight d4
threatening to fork i don't see anything
wrong with this
yeah yeah this is where you have to
remember these ideas
if you are clearly winning right you
have to count the material to make sure
but if you're up on material you just
have to automatically go into trade mode
i think in this situation and rusted
just slow rolling it instead
and that's not really gonna work out
you have to see one of these two moves
takes i and you cannot take here okay
you have to see takes and takes or you
just have to take on g5 one of these
moves
has to be played
oh my gosh let's see what e thinks about
this position dude sharp
games this is great
and wrestig takes
[Music]
like they have to deal with so they have
to take right now
and there is a tactic here i hope he
finds it he's looking at the bishop
backing up but there is a small tactic
that wins another pawn here
[Music]
okay that move actually has to be pretty
scary for russia and i feel like i want
to listen in to see
how scary he thinks that might be
feeling like his rook
got trapped actually because if i go
here
he would just take he obviously just
takes and here he just takes
um but if i move
that's not good because he just takes
there but then at least i save the rook
but i might do this first because then
it's a rook for rook but he'll move i'll
do that threaten the other work
um he'll move that
there might be something there
i wonder if there's any other ideas
because i do have my rook
i wonder if like i can't obviously go to
e but um
yeah put him into check he takes i could
then move my rook back
and then i'm threatening his bishop but
he's going to move the bishop
but i'd rather lose a bishop than lose a
uh i could still make both moves
actually so i'm going to do that
do this first because i take the pawn at
least this way
yeah but i think it's about order of
operations right the move order matters
here
and russia may have not used the best
order
move order is definitely a thing here
and
i mean his his line makes a little bit
of sense i mean
you're going to get back to peace but at
least you're still in the game
and you know you get bishop to b7 and
all we're going to do is maybe
just like king up right and obviously
we don't play here right that would be a
disaster
because of the discoveries that are
possible in the position
or just even like rook here and then
we're threatening some really really
nasty ideas
yeah this is becoming awkward and
dangerous for rustic now
man what is going on you could have at
least had the bishop for
the rook that was lost right and that's
kind of the thing if you know that that
material is gone
then you kind of have to ask is there
anything i can get for that right is
there any compensation
for that situation what is what is the
most i can get out of a
being in a bad spot
what would be really cool is if panics
and like plays like rookie 3 to try to
threaten the bishop while getting out
and then he plays e4 and he's able to
get out
um
okay this is a this is a very
interesting spot here
this is this is very interesting because
now
we can actually do a really really cute
idea you asked me
wow that that wasn't the key that was
not it
wasn't an idea that was so not it oh
no oh man
the idea was just to play it to rook f8
because the you can't take here because
we have checked
the rook yes oh boy but rustage
um man that is too deep
and i think e sam is in a
is in a situation where he's just
probably talking about how to win this
game
not a terrible moon well it is terrible
because then i just take the road
[Music]
like what this this is protected
there's no where to go he's finding
okay
yeah and with uh less than three minutes
on the clock this is just too tough i
think for russia to come back from at
this point
[Music]
he'd have to find some way to make this
really awkward
yep it's lower over till it's over yeah
he's got to find a way to make this
too awkward for esam to easily convert
sure and i can't actually protect here
because then you just take upwards
the thing is actually if i can just take
out this then i have a nice
path with my pawn up here
it's a nice thought but usually you need
that rook to be behind the pawn rather
than in front of it
i'll take it oh boy oh
that was a blunder i didn't see that
that was a blunder oh well
that was definitely just a blunder i
tried really hard to not do any actual
blunders during this game
but that 100 was just a blunder i just
blunted my rook but it's okay
it's okay man
there we go
yeah yeah blunders yeah i had a couple
blunders
okay
several this is all fine i was like
all right i started this like
maybe shouldn't have done that wow
that's it ecm punches his ticket he's
going to the grand finals
but i have to say that this is probably
the most composed
version of rustage that i have seen
probably in either tournament arc
and i think the quality of his choices
was improved
simply by not letting his emotions
push him into thinking that that all was
lost at any point
this is quite the game for us and i
think this
this is like rustlers 2.0 honestly i i
think that he was playing much stronger
moves
um although he's a little bit he's
panicking on time
but he's playing great moves and i think
with a little bit of practice
and refining of the skill i think he's
going to be a great player
yeah well he does take home third place
which i think is pretty fantastic uh
to also mention the fact that he placed
higher in tournament arc two than connor
he's gotta be happy about that
he's going to sleep on who's floor now
well i know connor is listening to me
connor i'm sorry i had to go there
uh but look that was great
and we are going to go to a break and
when we come back we'll interview both
players and then we will set up for the
grand
final don't go anywhere we'll be right
back
sorry i had to go there wait what did he
say i didn't hear what he said
that was great and we are going to
go to a break and when we come back
we'll interview both players and then we
will set up for the grand
final oh we'll be right back
sorry i had to go there wait what did he
say i didn't hear what he said
that was great hold on i'm going to hit
myself now
nice got ourselves a queen
uh
oh no
that was a misclick oh god on chess.com
stream two this is embarrassing
oh gosh i was low on time anyway it's
fine it's fine
classic all right it's all right
your mic just blacked out for a second
there um i wonder what's wrong
okay
uh uh seems to be a problem with the
software
uh
i really hope
yeah it's uh it seems to be a problem
with my
with the go xlr software seems to be
re-eating out
uh you know what i've just started the
stream but i'm going to restart my
computer
um thank you very much for the
subscription man um because i'm not
gonna be able to
play around with this while
be playing in the tournament so i'm
going to restart my computer and hope
that fixes everything
um okay i'll see you guys
back in a bit
my
[Music]
so
all right we're here with the players we
got e salmon rustage in here and
we wanted to actually review some
moments from from
one or two of your games here before we
just kind of dive in with some q
a so jt maybe you could pull up a moment
or two that we can
uh take a look at from what was really
some impressive chess
yeah i really like the opening
choice taking immediately and
here russ stage i already thought that
in my mind you won the game
did you think so because like like rated
queens sorry we traded queens and you
can't blunder it anymore so i was like
that's why i did it yeah is that really
why you did that
i i mean i think it's a good move anyway
because it it means you can't uh castle
anymore and yeah
so it's like even though it's an equal
piece thing you can't cast anymore so
it's a slight advantage to me
but i also did it because yeah then i'm
not at risk of blundering my queen
anymore i could blunder other pieces but
that's not as
stressful i think the only peachy
blunder was at the end like the very end
oh yeah the very end yeah yeah yeah
100 that was that was definitely a
blunder um but i think at that point it
was like
you were dead you were kind of winning
at that point and um
yeah i honestly i like the way you guys
both played here like getting all your
pieces out attacking correctly
and here i feel like he said we could
have played bishop characters after
and the idea is a more of a strategical
one i know that bishops are usually
better in the end game right but if you
can play
captures here bishop captures in some
cases this pawn
is going to prevent this fish from
working and also your pawns are
preventing this bishop from working as
well
yeah right like if um if russia
immediately like after like he takes i
take
if he plays what e5 then my pawns just
kind of there i have to like move my
bishop really awkwardly
right right right right um and just the
fact that
like i was like oh okay now now it's
kind of uh
we now we want to trade because we know
that this pawn is going to be in the way
of our bishop so now we would love to
trade this bishop
for this bishop yeah and then like look
at 95
for example okay so um
g4 and the aggressive play i i like this
i love i love this game in particular
because you guys barely made any
mistakes in the opening
oh yeah i think i think opening wise
i'm pretty confident because i
the way that i practice for these
matches is i kind of run through all the
scenarios and the openings and stuff
because i know that
like my brain can't work that fast for
like analyzing board positions and being
able to figure out what will
work well yada yada especially on the
time that we have
so i like i go through like i looked at
esam's all of esam's games and see saw
like
what is his most common moves that he
did at certain points of the match
and how what is my best moves in those
situations
and like i and i sort of semi-memorize a
bunch of like
different things like that and so my
openings generally i don't make mistakes
in
even if i'm not doing anything great i
mean i didn't expect him to move that
pawn up to be fair
that that was i was aggressive with me
super aggressive he was like he was in
there
he was like yeah excuse me let me uh let
me see what you're gonna do with that
night is
um he was asking your night where it's
gonna go and then after 1964 this is
kind of scary
and i was wondering like you didn't play
king
d7 here like i thought you would you
were like
because i um i always forget
that my king is also an attacking piece
i guess
okay like outside of end game outside of
like outside
games so like i don't think about the
fact that i could use my king to defend
other pieces
i just worry about making my king more
vulnerable for some sneaky checkmate i
don't realize
god they've got it um i we listened into
isam here and he said pp on the pp and
it made me extremely proud
yes yes i was hoping you were watching
then because
obviously i would just say like oh yeah
i want to attack the pawn the pin
piece but i was like i remember you said
this in commentary a couple times i
think this tournament
and i was like please please be watching
me i can't tell because i'm not gonna
open the chest.com stream because i
don't wanna hear the commentary and get
coaching
um but i was like yes and then
immediately after the strategy i
blundered like four times because i was
just like this piece is hanging
and he's just not taking it like once uh
rustage castled
you could have just taken the knight on
d4 for like free for free because
there's nothing defending it
i i sometimes i think i i sometimes
focus so much on my
making sure i don't have anything
hanging in pieces
you're right it was just hanging at that
point yeah but i think uh
what was your next move after that
because i think there's a reason why i
didn't take it because i didn't know
yeah i went yes so obviously i couldn't
take it then
you could have you can i mean here is
like a perfect moment
because if i take it if you take and i
take your rook
you then take my bishop or you know the
bishop that's on like with your king so
like you you win six for five
so that's a good position that that's
that's my my problem
is that i knew that my work was in
danger
and i was like well yes i can take this
knight but i will lose my rook and
that's a bad trade
and i didn't really think ahead of that
and that's my problem i just i'm dummy
i'm a dummy brain
i don't understand what's good
those are really tricky sequences to see
for sure
and also you know like you said it's
tricky to see
king moves uh when there's still a lot
of pieces on the board right it's kind
of scary
um but i mean yeah you you had
some amazing choices to make and i think
you
developed some really great plans esam
definitely found
ways to kind of uh mix those up a bit
and make them difficult to execute but
yeah i mean the sharp games for
both games uh just like tactical feasts
and both of you did an amazing job my
best
i wanted to try i love this this right
here where he's just like okay
you were you were thinking about this
for a while like wait is that a free
piece is that a free piece
you're like overthinking it you're like
i don't want to plunder here is this a
free piece yes or no
and you end up taking it really fast and
i was like okay luckily he's not
spending five minutes
on determining whether this is a free
piece or not right
um so yeah again i was just worried
because
i think it's because i know he sounds
good so whenever he makes a move
i just assume it's not a blunder all
right the thing is also
again even relative like again maybe
comparatively sure i'm better but at the
same time we're all
average yeah so it's definitely like i'm
not playing anywhere like i get
you know my highest rating ever like in
terms of accuracy rating is 93 something
that's typically in like games that i
make one mistake in a 14
game game because i just resigned
because i take a piece early
um but like what i feel like one thing
that definitely hurt was you went for
the tactical thing game one because it's
like oh well
he's gonna pin my queen but i'm gonna
attack his queen first and then that was
wrong so you were like i'm scared to do
that again because i don't want to go
down a piece and that was probably like
in my head i'm like i think that's why
he's not taking immediately is because
he doesn't
like he's scared because the first game
was a mess up um i actually i don't even
know
i i don't think i was like affected by
the first game at all into the second
game i played them about the same
as i would i think i just i'm stronger
as white than i am as black
i actually i had more of a specific
counter to your
opening strategy with white you if you
noticed those first five moves were
really fast
because i was like he just you two
played all the moves i knew you were
going to play and i was like oh i just
do this
this this or this and but with black
you played i knew i needed i always just
carry khan
because it's the only thing i'm
comfortable with and then you played a
bunch of moves i've never seen anyone
play against the carrot card i was like
wait what the am i supposed to do
now
it went into like unknown territory very
quickly completely completely for me
when i was playing as black that's half
the reason i don't like it's so hard
for me to do opening prep because i'm
like i'm gonna like i remember when i
played in the smashers game but a couple
months ago i was like i'm gonna do all
this opening prep and then one move is
different and it changes
like literally everything so i was like
like i literally had like this whole
plan
sequenced with uh my coach anna maya and
she like
everything happened and then one move
was different but i did this like the
same sequence same sequence
and it was wrong then because yeah
because
yeah so i get that i did that against
tech tone i think hard
it's so hard yeah i mean chess is hard
i'm not
i'm not good at it i'm not good at it at
all
but i appreciate yeah get getting the
opportunity to play and i appreciate any
opportunity to play against you esam
you're the only smash player i know
thank you
i don't watch smash because i'm bad at
fighting games um
but i have watched some smash and you
you're the only smash player i've ever
watched so
it is it is an honor to to play against
you mr e sam
thank you i appreciate it yeah and so
esam now
you have won the redemption final
and are going to play giggup next in
just a few minutes you'll get a short
break and then
basically what i want to ask you here is
you know you faced him once before
and you lost and that's why you ended up
in the redemption arc to begin with
so now it's kind of a twofold question
have you prepared for you know feeling
like you're gonna
get that rematch anyways and also what
are you going to do
with the 10 minutes that we're going to
give you before you have to play again
against giger who's probably proven
himself in the course of this tournament
to be the strongest player thus far
first off i'm going to beat his ass no
i respect every player that's just a
little bit of trash talk but um
i haven't done opening prep versus him
because again i kind of just play the
same openings
like the same two and again like my
thought process is
oh i would have won against gigguk had i
taken more time
in the very key moments so i'm just
gonna do that
and you know i may have played a little
quickly last game i've definitely had
like 9 minutes and 15 seconds when i
made my consecutive blunders with the
knight
um but you know i just want to play a
little bit better i'm probably going to
grind tactics in the 10 minutes because
i think honestly like me and giga were
pretty
rarely hanging pieces like really
hanging pieces
so i'm just i just want to get those
little tactical edges
uh and if he wins he got it and if i win
i'm goaded so
yeah fair enough
and russet obviously this means that
it's the end of the road for you in
tournament arc but you take
third place which i would say it's
exciting
yeah that's pretty awesome and i
actually connor
connor deserves it so i'm gonna
honorarily give up my third place to
mr connor um i beat him too let's go
uh i mean me and connor can play a game
off stream and
he can beat me and and he can feel like
he's earned third place
actually if conor's listening i really
wanted to play you again so i'm a little
bit disappointed i didn't get to
because when we played last year i i
totally just blunted both games and
i wanted to have like an actual match
against you into which i prepared for
so at some point whenever you want to i
know you're a busy guy but whenever you
want to i'd love to
actually have a game against you at some
point and i think that would be fun
um yeah yeah everyone else has never
fallen into it
yeah this is the nicest call-out i've
ever heard for real
yeah whenever you have a chance i would
love to play against you just once
well you know god is a busy guy i don't
want to like i don't want to like bother
him or take up his time if he has to do
other things y'all all have over a
million subs you're all busy
right right right right right after this
is done i have to go right back into
working on my album and working on
my stuff i'm really behind work because
i'm busy thinking about chess
well everybody should definitely go
check out your youtube channel for sure
it's one of my favorites as well and
you're also just one of my favorites in
terms of like people who've
played in this tournament this year and
um
and we want to say thank you for
participating hope you had fun
and hope you'll consider joining us
again if we have a tournament arc three
and e sam
uh you are gonna get your break oh i
have to remember
we're gonna do a coin flip right now uh
so you've got to call heads or tails
uh to see if you get the white pieces
against gigan smacks you ready heads or
tails for white
tails all right here we go
oh wow you got it bro okay you see him
cool so you get the white pieces against
gigguk and uh of course
uh you to beat him twice that's the
thing right gigging only has to win one
match
you've got to take him to a second best
of three and defeat him there
we wish you the best of luck and we will
see you in about 10 minutes or so for
your first game
thank you i appreciate the luck because
god it's going to be difficult
it is going to be difficult good luck
thank you i am rooting for gaunt though
i have room for god though
that's fine all right y'all see ya
there you go that's the players esam
moving on to the grand final
rusted shaking third place not too
shabby and uh
there you have it you could take a look
at the bracket right there and see esam
has had
the longest path of any player
to get to where he is now he uh
he beat sagam to stay in the winner's
side of the bracket after the first
round but then
fell to giga two to one drop down into
the redemption arc defeated tektone two
to zero moved on
defeated sea dog va two to zero and now
has beat rustage two to zero
and uh he's climbing his way back
meanwhile gigguk has been able to just
like go to the spa
get a lot of sleep over sleep only had
to play a few matches to get where he's
going but
hey there's a reason for that right he
he won every single match kind of uh
a nice little bonus for that right
i mean that seems like the life right
like hey uh
delayed my match i'm gonna go use the
restroom real
um quick yeah i mean he's he's been
great and
he's won every single game so i'm just
rooting for the best player to win at
this point
yep and uh i want to reiterate the fact
that
because the way a double elimination
bracket works is basically
uh everyone has to lose twice
in order to be eliminated now gigguk has
not
lost a match at all and so what that
means is
if he loses this best of three against
esam
he actually gets a reset because he'll
have only lost
once and so he's insulated there and
that if he wins this first best of three
it's over
right esam will have lost twice at that
point
and uh giggup takes the whole thing home
so what esam
must do here is he must win
this first best of three and then take
it to a second match where he then
still has to win that match in order to
take the championship so
we are going to find out we are just
moments away
from the concluding match of tournament
arc three so
do not go anywhere we will be right back
with the the last of the last guys esam
versus giggup for
the championship we'll see you in a
moment anything about that
that is uh it's not something i want to
do as a forfeit
of tournament arc three so do not go
anywhere
we will be right back with the
i really i really hope uh my brain
doesn't need to uh
have time
oh it is me it is me all right well
hello welcome to the windows pov um
i'm here to get my second tournament win
today
we're not we're not here to choke we're
not here to choke connor connor this is
for you this is for you connor
because i know it was it was all
scripted for you
to win today i mean for god's sakes
today was your birthday connor today was
your birthday
so don't worry don't worry don't worry i
i
i know i know you want me to win as your
birthday present don't worry no i i got
you bro i got you
honestly
all i can say is it's coming home lads
it's coming home
[Music]
look i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna dispel all
the bad omens
regarding regarding england and it's
coming home and tournament wins
i've already done it once i'm two for
two for tournament so far
um one one chest torment one one
shadowverse tournament
so i want to be three for three for
tournaments
i can't wait till like uh i can't wait
till this day ends and you just
you can just clip that and it's just
like moments before disaster
just watch me play the worst chess i've
played in this entire tournament
you can't ironically he's really good at
motivational speeches no i'm not
conor said his christmas dream is to
have giggup az animes i'd win today
uh don't worry i've in in true gbc
fashion i've
channeled the spirits of c dog va
right now you're watching g dog a z
uh i i this is like this is like when
goku and vegeta fused
into vegito um and i'm not sure how isam
can possibly take on g-dog a-z
say your joke
[Laughter]
no no i won't choke that's that's why
that's why i removed the c part from my
name
remember not to lose and then you'll win
don't worry i know i i i will try to
try to remember not to lose
i should probably close this shouldn't i
great we should be starting at just over
10 minutes from now at uh
18 past all right oh
i will assume that's right and i will
switch chats to
emotes only modes uh very very soon
incognito video ac yeah and i've learned
my lesson from last time
all right lads i've got this let's go
play my game
don't up don't make any stupid
moves
think i've got this i mean how can i
lose i've got the power i've got an
anime on my side
people lose when they are defeated
god what was your rating in the first
tournament uh my rating my love the last
tournament was about 900.
so you know this is this is this is me
having my time skip
um and having powered up since the last
tournament but they
work like in true anime fashion the
opponents are also stronger this time
connor's now a thousand twelve i mean
conor was doing like a bunch of
practicing
so uh i i'm i'm not surprised his rating
dipped a bit my rating also dipped in
practice
uh luckily i got it back up
i wish we hear the master from code
yesterday if i win
if i win i will play the master once
again
i'll i'll actually get it ready just in
case just in case
just in case we win just in case
but this this is this is only reserved
for if we actually win today
like the last tournament arc
[Music]
we keep drinking you bro yeah
a lot of a lot of bad omens going about
but we're not gonna think about that
we're not gonna think about that
i just hope i play better than i have
been playing as black
[Music]
make sure you king sacrifice don't worry
don't worry if uh
if esam gets too close then
i will just i would just lead with the
king
right i've watched code kiosk that's how
you play chess right
just lead with the king don't worry i'll
i'll go and truly lose fashion
right right because that's how to lose
one that's not a loose one just leave
with the king so
um basically if i move the king
first that's like a really op move
so i'm probably gonna open with that
all right um giga talking about how he's
gonna open to try to maybe mess with
east sam's
head a little bit e sam did win the coin
toss during the interview and so he will
start with the white pieces
uh which maybe he considers a
significant advantage because
if gig only needs to win the first best
of three
to take the whole thing home then maybe
esam can set the mood if he wins with
white in the first game
definitely and this game
is not one-sided i think it's still
toss-up um
raiding wise i think esam
is the slight favorite or although over
the course of tournament i think
duke has been gaining a lot of rain
because he's been playing more and doing
some tactics
um so esam definitely i think it was a
top seed but let's see what happens
because
igook won the uh the first match between
them
so this is actually if they go into the
second match that would be three matches
between them
yep that's true um
right that's crazy that's crazy to think
about
and uh the games will start soon e sam's
maybe consulting the oracles on how he's
gonna defeat
the uh the current uh reigning champion
of the tournament arc series gecko beat
seadog
in the finals of tournament arc one with
a
win and a draw after c dog repeated the
position
uh which was crazy and this was back
when this was a two game mini match so
winning a draw was all it took to win
we uh made the it made the rules a
little bit more
i think exciting this time around making
it a best of three rather than a two
game mini match so
there's more opportunity for the other
player to come back
uh and stay in it for maybe a third game
after a draw
so yeah i mean you guys obviously in the
chat can let us know if you were there
for both tournament arc one and two
how do you feel about the updated format
do you like it do you think uh
best of two is better we also changed
the time control i think
i don't know that we did ten plus five
last time i think it was
less times maybe only five five so we
wanted to make sure we get more chess
and uh using the ten five time control
also kind of
guarantees in a way that it's more
likely the outcome
will uh happen on the board rather than
on the clock and i think we have seen
in more matches than not that that has
been the case in tournament r2
i mean jt what do you think we we made a
lot of changes to the form but also the
double elimination like
how has this season gone for you do you
like it
i like it i like seeing good chess and i
think
bernard too delivered when it came to
good shots it was it was great
what what happened was you know we got
more time we got the increment
we have also the blitz playoff at three
minutes right which is a great time
because now you have faster chests as
well so we're testing
you know the good long calculated chest
and now
we're going for the super fast
how fast can you think chess so it's a
great transition
as well as you know the the loser
bracket
being a thing you know that that was
that's an awesome addition
so you know thank you for everything
that you put
together on that it was amazing well i
don't know man i actually think that the
double elimination thing was your idea
after
i told you we were going to invite some
fighting game players you were like well
you know man they have this beautiful
like bracket you should
yeah you you explained it to me and then
i fell in love with it so
um i'm trying to give you the credit
here and you should you can just take it
no all right well the games are going to
get underway
and uh yeah esam
has the climb he's got to win two
matches so i want to check in on his
move as these first moves get underway
see if he feels like he can do it
opening prep for game
for when i'm black until i'll do it
between one and two
[Music]
okay moves coming fast
dude i love just like pushing the pawns
like that
[Music]
do
yeah man that pushing that e5 pawn makes
it really difficult for black to
figure out an easy way to develop that
knight right because even now after
they've
recaptured the pawn still sits on e5 the
knight
wishes it could go to f6 but it can't i
mean
this is a pretty common theme right jt
to just make it tough for black to
develop
yeah i mean and i think here
it kind of did some stuff with the uh
weird move order right
normally we would love to see this pawn
pushed here and now the bishop is behind
its own pawn
although you can be a little bit tricky
here i think the the move maybe was to
play 97
and be a little bit tricky more you
always have that move and the idea is to
that maybe we can take here
and be just fine in some lines
okay man e sam said he did not prepare
uh against gigguk and when we talk about
preparation we talk
simply just reviewing their games and
seeing what they like to play and
also trying to look for things that that
they that they
lose to right moves that they just can't
seem to work out
uh and if you can remember those things
find yourself in that position then you
take advantage of that
um but hey i mean maybe the lack of
preparation on e sam's part is gonna
bite him in the
end uh or maybe it's gonna work out
maybe the the sort of
just plan of aggression is gonna be good
enough let's listen to
giga who i think is doing a little bit
more
calculating in these early stages
like i literally mess up once
i literally do run one wrong move in the
sequence
and esam has absolutely pounced on it
uh maybe i want a castle let's see let's
what if i kick you out first
all right that's
gives me a bit of space at least um
there's no light square bishops anymore
so i'm probably going to castle now
oh that's that's a weak pawn
some good observations yeah
uh should i call it it needs to be
played here
yes castle or should i castle kingside
queensland now castle kingside
okay so you know this is where we see
kind of the difference here
rustage developed some plans but then
ultimately kind of backed away whereas
giga is kind of saying like
all right here's a plan i'll maybe
measure one other option but not spend
too much time and then
if if if the other thing doesn't really
you know
tickle my fancy then we'll go back to
what we already decided we're going to
do
i know you love that the phrasing oh
man um i think love is a strong word but
he's
british okay fine
i i actually like the way slang he's
like
he know he notices that he has a
really really bad pawn here on e6 and
then we have esam just playing b4 and
saying hey you cannot take this this is
defended by my queen
where's your bishop gonna go you let me
know
yeah this is this is tough i mean this
is kind of what comes if you let that
e5 happen then your position is cramped
and difficult to develop and like
uh but you know let's think about this
if esam wins giga will play as
white and if he wins then giga
in the third game will play as black and
maybe it's an opportunity for him to not
allow this
in that game you gotta learn the lesson
i mean there's only really like one
place right
yeah there's either v6 a7 or the fancy
move b4
oh that is fancy schmancy
because at the end of the exchange you
have the tempo on the knight on c3
exactly and finally you know after these
moves we have like knight g6 but i
really want to
see what e7 is thinking because maybe
he's not thinking like that at all maybe
he's thinking that he's going to get all
this pressure on
the king's side yeah maybe he's just
think he's trying to trap the bishops
but it doesn't
really work
[Music]
that pawn with check
okay getting a knight back into the game
oh i have this ooh
he not go off is that mate
because it's this i mean i guess he can
run away but then i take his queen so
he's so i would do this he takes i
take with check has to go there and then
he's missing the rook capture so it
doesn't really work out
or i win a queen
fine by me
oh man if this happens that's
crazy move that's a crazy
sequence if giga plays a patient move
and e sam falls into this bad exchange
by i'm nasty i mean
uh okay
[Music]
okay crisis actually averted for esam
now because gig actually
blocked the discover check that esam
thought was gonna be a winning
um sequence so now we're back to
his original plan uh pushing the pawns
making it
even more awkward for those bishops
right
well oh i don't like this idea at all
right the knight takes here
oh yeah you're attacking our queen so we
have to move our queen great but what if
we attack your knight
then it becomes a double attack
oh did you play that a little bit too
fast
um let's see what
you're saying because there's no way
yeah
sorry i'm still in the game
this
[Music]
when he finds queen g3
is there anything i can do
i've lost the bishop so that's gone
that's fine
that's been sacked i've sacked that
um trade
takes
i really don't want to suck more
material
this is really really difficult
takes takes
all right i've just got to do it
[Music]
okay now here's the thing i feel like
gig maybe isn't it possible that you
could have chosen
which bishop to keep rather than just
saying
that that is the bishop that's going
down in the exchange because
maybe bishop takes knight knight takes
knight retreat the dark square bishop
and hold on to it
or just play bishop a7 and then let them
take your knight right you could have
maybe just played back
and then let them take your knight ah
yeah yeah
also an option but then after that
knight c5 is uh
pretty fierce as well
um it's up to them to see it and also
rook f5 yeah
i think i think black would have been
better than that one i think i agree
with you
yeah because now the rook is activated
whereas
it couldn't get to that square before if
you just leave the pawns where they are
hmm right i mean this is
this is a great first game esam
is taking full advantage of the way that
he opened this
and uh gigguk has just not been able to
really reach into the other side of the
board
i wonder how isam is feeling now that he
has a material lead
on good he's probably nervous coming
into the match but
now he's probably just chilling
huh
[Music]
i mean it might work i'm just a little
slow on it
[Music]
it's hanging by a thread here
cook actually gives up the pawn here on
c7
in order to pin defend the center bond
but i don't know maybe you want
maybe you like your center pawns i
actually don't even want to go for that
pawn i would rather play rookie one and
activate
all of my pieces
i just play something like this and just
activate all of my pieces and there it
is
yeah yeah the the prophet himself
oh yeah yeah stop steering the course of
this competition
dude this is man what a game gig in the
corner here
um fighting for his life it feels like
and wow white has so many
potential plans whereas black is just
trying to hold right
something's going to get over right
i mean we just kind of have to not allow
this one move
my block b6
and we should be okay
okay although we just we do have to keep
defending we do have to keep defending
and stuff like that but
yeah so you don't allow that one
isn't e5 kind of kind of nice here
because now you've
pushed it into a square where it has two
defenders
against uh the two attackers although
it's like 2.5 because the the rook
x-rays
right right and that's actually a good
point because
here we have two defenders but
this is pinned right so this pawn
becomes extremely weak
and we can force you to push because if
we move this knight away then this rook
is also attacking
oh wow instead uh e sam goes for a check
uh but there's not an immediate
continuation with that
uh maybe he's maneuvering with uh b5 on
on on his mind something like that
interesting i mean otherwise what's
what's the
what's the purpose of bringing the queen
over to the other side like that
yeah let's uh let's check in with you
see if he sees what we don't
oh okay interesting
oh that's this is horrible because even
if i move that
then he goes there and it's a fork
[Music]
so i guess my only option is to go there
the show they're sure
yeah i gotta go there
maybe i go there um
trade works and then
yeah okay oh no then it's just the queen
sack
oh man but if there wasn't that knight
on d2 there's puzzle rush man
right it could have been
this position is a whole puzzle rush too
wow yeah yeah yeah if we could we go
back a bit
while the queens were still on the board
there just enough to see
after queen f7
if the knight moved to a square that
didn't defend f2 then you've got the
nice queen takes f2
check followed by queen f1 check rook
takes rook takes and it's mate because
now the king is in the corner
interesting yeah just sticks here
mg oh
so actually the knight didn't have to
move for this to be possible
that's pretty cool but the queen trade
happens
and we continue to move forward in the
game but look at these pawns by black i
mean
yeah you've got two knights and they're
gonna start to chew up on them they're
tricky
but i wonder if there's a way for giga
to make something out of this
i don't know i eastern has i think the
better
game here but he has to solve the
problems i'm wondering if he can do that
within the time
that he has he has four minutes on his
clock and he's probably thinking
so let's listen in and yeah see what he
has for us
i just gotta convert this
because here it takes takes aches
not threading the check can't even check
me with the bishop
knight or some only moves here
i take this
[Music]
you literally cannot take this
ah this is annoying this is annoying
i literally had i literally had the
choice to go either
for sake i lost anyway
that was that was a disaster for me that
was that was a disaster
didn't matter i would have lost anyway
i think i got really tilted um after
that first
it wasn't an opening blunder but i just
messed up my opening
really badly wow
dude look at that gigguk falls
in the first game and uh i wonder how
that's going to affect his mood i mean
he gets the white pieces in
in in the second game and we'll see what
his prep looks like but
like that just could be a shock to your
to your confidence
definitely shock to the system there
because it could lead to a whole bunch
of downfalls like oh i played so badly
this
last game let me not try to play so
badly this game and then you start
overthinking and then protecting things
that don't need to be protected so
oh man i hope that you know gabe calms
down but esam you need to keep doing
whatever you're doing
you need to keep doing whatever it is
that you're doing because you're on a
roll man
yeah and uh yeah
question for you maybe i think i saw it
in the chat
what if they draw right so let's say the
next match
they draw and give when's the next game
we go to a blitz playoff and then they
go to the second match if esam wins
yeah yeah because it's still a
self-contained match so even if they go
into a tiebreaker and e sam wins that
one
it doesn't change the fact that gigguk
has still only lost one match
and the brackets uh mean that he has to
still lose
two it's yeah so i mean this could be
crazy exciting gigguk
has to bring this thing back uh the fact
is
he can stay calm because even if he
loses this first best of three it's
not over by any means they play another
best of three so
just i think for giggup don't let this
first loss get to you don't let it guide
your emotions towards the future of
of uh what's to come and yeah so stick
with it and you guys stick with it as
well we're gonna take a break we'll be
right back
with the second game stick around
so good so good we'll play the next game
it's just a warm-up game just a warm-up
game who's messaging me
[Music]
oh i got my shot later today
so good
like let me see
where i mean it went wrong straight from
the beginning
i just was not comfortable playing this
at all
like this is just super super methodical
play by izam
[Music]
that goes there
let me turn off notifications
so good it's all good it's all good
we got what we got why next we got
whites
it was just a warm-up game what what
kind of uh what kind of finals would it
be
if uh we didn't if we didn't even uh if
it wasn't tense it wasn't if it was
intense right
[Music]
like next time i'm going to go a little
bit
slow on the opening i shouldn't have
done that i feel
[Music]
maybe i'll try a different opening next
time i said i had the i actually had the
advantage here
if i just went there i didn't feel like
i had the advantage
um i thought i guess it's a pretty
decent position
i'm so stupid i didn't even see the rook
going back
the bishop going back sorry god i'm
out of it
all right next game can't dwell on past
i think i spied uh just watching the
screen share there with giga
likes 83 to 91 percent
cap score on that last game like wow
wow for gig even though we lost the game
to still have
pretty decent accuracy but then also wow
for esam over 90 percent
like wow
what
no they're both playing really good
chess and we we knew that
going into this match we saw their last
game they were both making extremely
good moves and
they're executing good ideas so
i'm really excited for this next match
to go underway
and what do you think is going to happen
here i'll let you predict it this time
um i say giga turns this around and
either gets a draw or a win i don't
think esam wins as black here
especially because he's
okay so he still plays g6 he's doing it
a little different order than he's done
before but it's the same opening setup
so i don't know
i'm saying gigguk does improve this game
and uh wow look at this
this is similar to something russet had
but didn't necessarily play in that last
game
yeah this is actually a very interesting
spot here for
white this is actually a very
interesting spot
uh the king is here in many cases we
just want to push
h4 and i would have pushed h4 when the
bishop was still
on h6 right because then they can't push
h5 oh
that's neat okay
see what he says thinking about his
position because he's the one that
probably is going to have to defend its
position
yeah he might not be feeling this right
now
[Music]
i actually don't have this doesn't
protect it at all
i'm doing this for this pumpkin
i guess
i don't i can't have that tempo
h4h5
immediately get good goes for the break
so yep his plan and your plan are
aligned about how to deal with this
structure and
yeah i mean this is kind of the risk of
playing that fiancee bishop as black
there is
once the king is in that spot you bust
it open
whoa yeah i think
i think it's um we have a good advantage
just by taking here g5 dislodged the
knight
the knight is the protector of the pawn
so he has to move and then we just went
up free
pawn oh man but i mean giggix focus
is maybe not really in the center right
now so
he might not see it let's take a look
and he has to take
do i take he takes
do i go there first
[Music]
hmm
so many options um
let's uh let's break it up let's break
it up
all right what i appreciate from that
is two things one it is hard to spot
moves that remove a defender
and two he didn't spend too much time
either
making the choice about how to proceed
here right
it definitely could feel like a critical
moment for a gig
and i do like the fact that despite
that potential um he had a plan
and he's moving forward yeah i mean i i
think
this decision makes a lot of sense we're
trying to open up the g-file
although in these positions or these
kinds of positions
we normally don't want that knight here
because the knight cannot it's very hard
to dislodge this knight from the square
and then they have moves like rook h8
that make it even harder
and now you have no attack right one of
the
ideas in this position is maybe to trade
off this
knight and put a pawn on f6
actually this isn't a a very famous it's
not a famous book
i want it to be famous it's in a book by
daniel gormali mating the castle king
um it's such a strong idea there's so
many chess.com
um puzzles like this as well if you go
to like puzzle puzzles you'll see
ideas like this so if you're trying to
get stronger chest by the way free hint
that's the calm tactics yeah and
just so people see obviously uh e sam
can't take the pawn on f4 because then
the queen will take back
and it's no bueno um the
pawn on d5 also still hangs
it's attacked 2.5 times defended once
i say 0.5 because the rook also is
sitting there
staring it down through the queen so
even if you move the queen you still
have two attackers one defender
yeah and then you also have moves like
knight take d5 and then queen c3 check
right
and when you check this knight isn't
or or not or not
you know maybe uh maybe e3 what is e3
threatening though
yeah i think it just activates the
bishop
but i think he moves like knight g3 here
or d4 which is i think the strongest
move in the position
um is going to cause a little bit of
trouble
yeah let's uh take a listen here i think
esam maybe
felt he was on the back foot for a
moment but now he's working his own plan
to push forward
[Music]
like stuff trades i take this pawn
like it's like trades trades and then
like forces a trade here
[Music]
but then it's i lose a pee honestly i
think i'd rather
think with this oh this is not
this does not work
that's unfortunate that wasn't what i
wanted to do
i didn't think i had that enabled
[Music]
i think one of the few moves that he can
play here in this position
because ng3 is looking at it is he going
to play it
yep 93 on the board yeah good job good
job finding one of the best
moves and the best resources for your
position
yeah i mean
this is tough right because e sam
needs to win this game at least mentally
thinking i gotta win this game to just
put this first best of three behind me
and even it up
um and so whereas giga can
just kind of let this go it's it's not
as
scary i don't think right
so maybe giga because
dude i don't know i mean nerves count
yeah it's it's tough and
we we see moves like maybe like knight
f5 because this bishop is
good but i think this knight might be
better and if we ever trade off
knights or bishops here then the other
bishop is going to become pretty active
on the square
especially looking at c2 and defending
the king's side
right and that's that's that's what i
envision
uh we also have a move like 97 then
going to f5
right and then this night is just
annoying it's almost like an octopus
except we don't have uh we can only go
to six squares instead of
eight that's a term actually coined by
uh
gary kasparov the octopus
yeah and i agree with his position
knight f5 is a very very strong move for
black
but you have to keep fighting these good
moves because right now you're
you're on the back foot you know you're
getting pushed yeah but h5 is scary
right
if you take you expose your king and
then there's
you know rook checks maybe the bishop
gets out of the way of the queen and now
we're looking at mate
yes so what i would suggest is just to
trade queens for esam
by playing like queen e3 and just saying
hey i'm going to trade queens and
it's not as scary with the queen off
let's look at what giga
is uh talking about
i think his plane of attack makes sense
but uh
now he's gotta think twice here okay
now is it time to bring my knight into
play
i think now
[Music]
now's the time now's the time
now is the time to bring my knights into
play
gentlemen it is time
all right well how do i want to do this
we want to make him squirm guys what's
the right way to do it
uh there's a
good old checks captures and threats
also asking the chat for help
is illegal so just be careful there
emotional
emotional support uh but man i mean
rook g1 check feels kind of nice here
oh yeah right rox g1 is nice and also
just d5
saying hey get your knight out of here
we might have some squares that we can
usually see through in the future
uh maybe bishop d3 knight e4 it could be
a possibility um so basically
being played right now yep
preparing for some things in the future
maybe preparing a queen g2 check
your 2 check is actually pretty strong
uh-oh
uh let me think about this knight takes
knight takes and
where does the bishop go try to maybe
discover an attack on the night
it's actually a little bit deeper than
that
so the idea here was actually
takes takes and then f5 because the idea
is that you're gonna play queen here
oh wow and then you've got a pawn that
maybe ends up on f6 and checkmate
right exactly and if we get this pawn
out of the way or on f6
it's mating this is what i was talking
to you you know the plan that was saying
before
so very interesting point yeah or so
queen gets to g5 rook takes a pawn i
mean there's there's a lot
okay wow i want to see how esam feels
with the pressure that he's potentially
facing here
[Music]
do has some
tactics here
[Music]
well i get to activate my rook finally
jesus
i don't get to move that
you just remember pp on the peepee this
gig
yeah well like knight g5 hit the bishop
that just blocked
something like that or is there
something better
hi this is pinned it's your move
yeah it's the pp on the pee pee
put pressure on the pin piece
all right put pressure on the pin piece
and even even now we can put
play f5 even now
yep because knight takes bishop takes
bishop takes
boom yeah yeah if the bishop takes then
we take the queen right yeah
right you always have to remember this
and i don't know how you can forget what
a saying like this
tp on the people
guys never forget that if you have a pin
piece always look to put pressure on the
pin piece
uh okay so now
ooh i don't know that i would have put
my queen in the line of fire after that
bishop moves
definitely definitely
although there's a sneaky idea
in some lines but honestly
just f5 would have won
you're attacking this knight but that's
what
here has to say about this oh
uh did esam just drop the knight
all right i think so and gig
that's all too happy to take free
[Music]
yeah i think that's free
and has checked the bishop's pinned
again
oh jesus gigguk is going to even this up
it's going to be 1-1
we're going to get a third game i think
with good play now from both players
and you said it and uh remember
commentators curse is a thing
i did say it commentators blessing in
this case we get what we want
right right right despite what the
players are playing dirty
was i got smooth maybe that rook there
really really fun to scare him
i could just play bishop
bishop f5 oh that's a good move
we're getting spicy tactical chest today
oh yeah my favorite this is great
the players are dropping a little
cholula on there
what's your favorite what's your
favorite hot sauce i bet you're a
tapatio guy
um well
i don't know there there's a korean hot
sauce that i like
but i'm gonna be honest i don't i don't
really
i just go to delhi because i'm in new
york and there's delhi in
every corner and i just get food there
so i don't have hot sauce
okay sauce that i like okay aloha sauce
like a really really spicy one oh
can't you do bishop takes e6
no because queen takes it every run oh
there is a brick
it has to be spicier you see like that
wasn't enough spice
oh man don't mean what
gig i need to see what is he selecting
what are his arrows
we gotta we gotta see it
[Music]
oh dude no
i mean it's probably still fine but free
stuff
if he takes it the wrong piece it's me
if he takes with the rook
we take stuff we're going to do like a
really beautiful checkmate but i just
do not have the time to work with right
now
okay good he missed it okay
because it is what the record would be
oh jeez
we dodged a bullet there guys hashtag
bless
this is so wild dude
all right now all he's got to do is just
be super annoying these have two pieces
right
two pieces oh we gotta do two pieces
and then once he plays f5 like the pawn
to f5
white's like super solid indestructible
i love when you can get the pawn and the
bishop
like locked up together where the bishop
protects the pawn the pawn protects the
bishop
like you have to sack something to st to
get rid of the situation
like yeah man giga just needs to trade
everything and win
that's it and even better even better
than that
it's a faster it's a pass bond there are
no pawns in front of
yeah this pawn so that makes it even
more powerful
it's natural now but he retreats the
bishop
i mean you could still play it you still
get a tip on the rook in order to
do the next thing that you want to do
but
gigguk would have to make some serious
mistakes here
to lose this if he ever moves
this rook off of the e1 square like
off the e files well just up the first
rank basically
yep you would you would just lose it
yeah because uh rookie one check after
the night blocks
other rook takes it's mate yeah
so we need to be very careful of that
man this is why i just want to i i want
to bring up both boards
i just want to stare at giggix rook
i don't only have two minutes
oh that's right wow both players have
just over two minutes here
okay the threat is still there
and gigguk might think he's safe on the
back rank because of the knight
okay decent move but he could have
played
rook h8 check trade the rooks that way
winnie
no no he's winning the rook there
because the rook
the king can't go to the e file because
the rook was on the e5
true yes
wow okay but this is still absolutely
crushing for giga
let's listen in a little bit he's going
to take this one
esam let's see probably
not jazzed about this
because then it puts him in a must
draw or win situation right
all right
they're both really close to being under
two minutes here
e7 being played right you sam
i don't know who knows i might get a
domain
not like that i won't wow
gig what a great
move tactical awareness trades off
esam's most valuable piece he's got to
be feeling good about that all right
i'm i'm i'm not going to still make this
this is this is the only thing i'm not
like i cannot do i'm just not going to
steal me
ah sake
i'm like i'm like really nervous right
now and
i really shouldn't be
i almost want to sack the rook for the
pawns and then just go for it
bring the king over and push
i like that idea do it
it's like i really should not be this
nervous even better just
e-sam makes it easier pushing the pawn
just allows the rook to get another pawn
and this is this is uh should be cut and
dry
what's funny here is that the rope has
no moves
that is kind of funny um yeah let's just
uh
oh that's cute it's very cute let's
cycle sack the bishop let's just let's
just
we know you know what let's just let's
just keep it simple
and the bishop's not sacked because esam
didn't take it
maybe esam's thinking that keeping the
bishop there makes tricky diagonals that
could help stalemate
kind of something eric rosen would pull
up
see i mean either king c6 or king d6
both work
the idea is rook a8 is me
man things were like kind of interesting
there and then
i think i made like one bad move i don't
remember like i can't i can't think back
up to like the tactic i messed up i mean
he just saw like a tactic
i mean that's kind of how you win chess
games
true you're not wrong there
you are not wrong that's kind of how
this works
giga's got a big smile
i hope he doesn't draw this hope he does
don't you say that shame on
i mean i i get to i think i'm here just
to sit here and look pretty and i can do
that for longer i shouldn't be fine okay
calm down
calm down calm down
all right telling us that's gone down
yeah he's got a minute and a half
there's plenty of time
i've been in this position so many times
before and i have
not i cannot it up
okay gets a queen it's not a stalemate
king has squares
still got that all right and it said
there's a checkmate in one i want to see
if he sees it
yep he's eyeing the rook should be it
right
okay i was only
okay chat i'm not normal i'm not
normally this nervous during
end games i just really didn't want to
throw okay
like normally i play this clean normally
i play this clean no pressure at all but
we're in the tournament finals here
we're in the tournament on finals i was
like sweating for no reason
i don't think it's for no reason but i
also don't think
that he didn't play that clean i think
it was a very clean game
i mean this is a very very important
game right and
just thinking about from the contestants
perspective
one game could cost you fifteen hundred
dollars
right one slip up think about that
one decision that's an expensive blunder
that's a very very expensive funder you
said the stakes were high
well you can't get that many stakes if
you are out fifteen hundred dollars
right oh my god dude you just
did you just did you're rubbing up on me
you're already off on me
did you just oh geez uh yeah yeah i
don't know if i should allow this
all right look we're going to take a
break the stakes
are super high
because if esam loses this game
it's over giagook will win tournament
arc
2. so esam's got to draw
he's got a win and take it to another
best of three we're gonna find out
this may be the most tense game
of the season so don't go anywhere be
right back
take this i like win
i mean the the misclick kind of
me i'm not gonna lie
not going to lie there were other
opportunities but like it was still bad
the p-chat also can one of my mods in
the prediction for that one
[Music]
hmm
oh i suppose if he had moved his bishop
there then i would have been
forced to trade queens oh yeah throwing
away my advantage i guess
i guess that did uh i guess that would
have thrown my
complete lead i guess uh
i guess we just didn't play that as
cleanly as i thought we did
oh well rip
yeah you can tell like we were in really
unfamiliar positions
um but i i think it's because like he
he knew that i knew he knew what line i
was going to play
so i've never actually played past
around this point before
so this is this is all like unfamiliar
territory for me
oh well a windsor wins a wind's a win
we have fun here
all right i just win one more game and
i've won tournament hawk again
ah what opening should i do this time
french really didn't work for me last
time
i guess i'll play a different kind of
opening we'll see how it goes
[Music]
i feel like both games today uh
whoever's gone white
has just had the initiative
and just had the attack and they have
just really really
pressured the other guy out
so i'm hoping esam doesn't do that in
the third game
really hope esam gives me a chance to
breathe when uh when i'm playing black
all right ready to get into it
all right well uh both players
off-screen taking advantage of the break
to
try to talk to themselves about what
they need to do um
dude i i just want to establish the
stakes here for a moment just
make sure everybody understands what
could happen
if gigguk wins this game
it is over and giga will win
tournament arc 2 having won every match
he has played
e sam on the other hand he's got to get
to another best of three and in order to
do that he's got to get to two points
uh either through drawing this game and
then going into a tiebreak and winning
that
and then he's got to get to two points
again so
like it's almost like he has to win
three games and gig only has to win one
in in a sense
well this one game is gonna decide the
faith right this
one game could be like okay
like the determining factor and this
i don't know it's kind of scary um for
islam because
he's in a must win must draw position
and then he has to win the blitz playoff
right so it's must win no matter what
which is really
scary it's so hard to go into that
feeling confident um you yeah even the
best players in the world don't want to
find themselves in that situation so
we are going to see uh the next game is
about to happen and it could be
the last game of tournament arc so
here we go opening moves i want to talk
about isam here because
honestly he's been in this position
before
he's used to the fgc he's used to
tournaments where he hasn't been
he's in must-win position he he does
this for a living
right
so let's see it's a good point it's
gonna be you know if it's
gonna be a good game or
[Music]
we're gonna have a second match and then
we're gonna have a third match in fourth
match because it's never gonna end
because we're gonna
keep getting draws the blitz playoff i
mean dude that that was actually a
really great point the fact is that esam
between the two of these guys is so much
more used to these kinds of scenarios
than
gigguk is and uh that might be what it
takes
to for him to have the nerves to keep in
this one so let's listen in and
see what's up with isaan
[Music]
look at this almost symmetrical
yeah this this position um
can happen in a few different ways but
yeah symmetrical and
after knight c3 yep there you go
but i actually think here that
black might be a bit better if they find
the right move
what you know and what did we say about
uh
you know the pin piece the papa papa
pop pop pop pop so ollie knew it before
she knew it right
because it's pp on the pp yep the
on the wow
man let's see if he's gonna see after hd
let's see what he's going to do
right here's the bishop taking with the
knight is a bit stronger
well now i mean i've seen similar
structures before that the double pawns
are not necessarily
the worst thing in the world but you
have to know how to
work with that and maybe he does maybe
he doesn't meanwhile
gigguk has natural development and
options of where to castle
and wow
and knight or king g2
what do you think about that movie i
don't know i don't agree with that at
all actually
um because i for me the very simple plan
would be
knight h5 i would love to play knight h5
here
play h6 this might be a
bit premature but okay you're just kind
of exposing your king after
we take yeah so now he returns the favor
giga also has double pawns this is like
talk about a mirror game like just kind
of continues
there it's almost like piccolo fighting
himself
splitting in half
it for hit that never made sense to me
like because if
if you're you you know every move that
you
are gonna use against you and so
how are you ever going to land a punch
against yourself i don't get it
well i think it was the subconscious
versus the cautious
conscious right and you could always
land hits because
they're never expecting it
there we go resolve now dank
so the idea here i think for for black
is just a castle
just this pawn is lost too fancy
nice yeah you gotta get away from losing
your queen
and then don't take here
that just opens up files um i'm
surprised
uh let's go into one of the players
lol i go there
that's that's the only square for i can
go to right
so is he going to go afterwards
okay let's calculate i'm in a winning
position here uh
much better position
um
know where he can go yes he has to go
there
let's go there
and you know how i like to play jt
how do you like if i'm gigging i i want
to sack the rook
rook she ate check knight takes rook g8
check
just to get activity on the king
okay no no no no no this is that's not
the way you proceed in this position
and this this position uh we want
the rook to go to g but we're not gonna
sack anything for it we want to play
queen h4
we want to get the rook on the g file we
want to play h5
pin to piece in some cases
um 96 and then knight f4 make a lot of
sense
oh there's some peepees here h5
yes yes he gets the king out of the way
ladies and gentlemen uh arn's learning
aaron's learning
i'm over here talking about pee pees
yesterday rush russia was talking about
poopoos
and then ollie starting it with
ollie's got some pop pops we have two
more vowels to attach to the p and then
we're
turning around too everybody
so the move here that i would love to
play i think it's just h5
either h5 or queen h4 just getting in
there
um i'm already looking at some ideas
right just
yeah i would love to get in there i
would love to play like 96
knight here and then queen here uh maybe
we can start that off
maybe with just h5 first and then 96.
yeah and also let's see if there's you
know knight takes a
f3 if e sam's queen goes to wrong square
like
there's a lot hanging in the balance for
e sam including the match i mean
if gigguk wins that's it all he gets is
second place
no bragging rights
i love the idea of like unpainting while
taking a piss
[Music]
i don't know what i'll do
too passive yeah i don't like it too
much
now we can force pieces to where we need
them to go as white
and what white needs to play maybe is
just c3 or rope
and i think they're in decent shape they
still need to make another few moves but
i think those are the two moves
and c3 being played here and here
yeah 96 i think is the correct decision
to go tonight
six months of coursing but
thank you
[Music]
yep so
stuff happening in game yeah i would
love both
both positions up like both viewpoints
or vantage points
because this is uh it's gonna get kind
of dicey very soon
that's so disgusting that i kind of want
it there i kind of want it there
yeah i kind of wanted that
i kind of wanted that that's such a
disgusting square for it
you it's not wrong
yeah getting nothing but facts if you
can get a queen on h4 next
yeah if you can get the queen on h4 it's
looking good like
lights out
a couple ways to defend it but
still not what you want it's not a
situation you want to be in
so the idea here there's a few ideas um
just queen h4
for the idea uh bishop captures f2
also works because the idea of
knight f2 recaptures
here and we you get you know you get
your little piece sack that you
wanted and we get in there see
i good thing sometimes too
me thoughts brain
[Laughter]
but yeah queen h4 are very natural spicy
nice just
[Laughter]
i'm taking too many notes from candy
with the rhymes
gosh you gotcha okay that's what it is i
was just like
it's the right who's teaching you
yeah i see okay
here we go and i i like it i we had to
find some
ways to like kind of mitigate the danger
and if you don't see that bishop
captures f2 is you know
is on pre or free
even though it's offended by the knight
but united's overloaded because
basically it's holding everything yeah
that's such a cool move i want to see if
esam knows what's next here
he's got to work this out so
[Music]
i don't remember my queen so i'm going
here
if we go here he can go here
oh that's bad
ah look at gigguk's screen
the arrow
he sees it he sees it guys uh
and esam may
actually provoke
oh man that just begs for the move like
then i have that
yeah i don't know but gig has to work it
out too
balls in the other goes the court
there's the
get that out
all right let me let me see this
let me formulate a plan of attack
properly
goes there now goes there or there
if he goes there i just take takes
[Music]
he's trying to solve a mate in seven
guys like that's what he's trying to do
right now
props potentially potentially
during our lesson we he was solving me
to talk about this
a little bit easier yeah he's his
calculation is really good in these
situations
seven brain uh he's definitely a
giga brain over here yeah and he drops
the kill boys
wow
interesting
donkey
oh he says don't care and then he's like
wait do i care
should i care sharing caring should i
really care about that
i think he has to care
honestly teach me he's a really good
attack
teach me he's a really good attack yeah
yeah sure
so he has a really good attack here why
care because if he takes here
then it's basically gg after you know
now our queen gets in
oh with discoveries with the discovery
and with everything it's everything is
just falling here night captures have
two checks out like
let's say you decide okay well i'm not
going to get made it here right
then therefore obviously you can't go to
the h file so you let's say you go here
and now rook h8 and you can't stop me
wowie wowie dude esam has just got to be
in the think tank
so bad right now because it is all on
the line
he loses this game that is the end of
[Music]
tournament
there might be a line where you sack
your queen here actually
yeah there there is a line that you sack
your queen here
and you win
let's see if uh the gear can actually
spot it
um it's obviously way to move but
yeah and if not we can definitely show
it
but the right ones have to be played
[Music]
i just can't move this rock
and he's hovering over square that's not
a legal move
[Music]
get the little red buzz
never a good feeling
yep can't go over there either we might
get the queen sack
we might get the clean stack going
i gotta bring up both boards here i want
to see if
we have to demonstrates what's on his
mind
and if queen f1 there is a sick tactic
super i don't expect it to see it but
there's a sick tactic of queen f1
look at this smile i'd be like oh
they might be like putting up one is you
know saves the day but queen of phone
actually leads to me
and it's it's very puzzle rushy you guys
are definitely going to enjoy it
oh i can't move like i move here
okay gig has not given away his plan
just yet
queen f1 okay so the move that he has to
see here guys
if he sees this he's a thousand brain
over here you guys ready for the move
are you guys ready for this was doing so
much
show me show me show me
the move that has to happen here
and i know all of you saw it in chat i
know all of you saw across everything
everybody who's watching the stream
um connor i know you're like why is this
guard playing this move already
is a bishop to g1 check
bishop to g1 now there are
three options right queen takes rook
takes
king moves back or king ticks right
um so let's say rook takes that's easy
queen captures h2 queen captures and
recaptures mate
because the rook is in the way of the
king and the knight covers his square
so you sack the queen right for me uh
the next one
if queen captures same idea
right the queen's in the way now
chapters
captures me
if the king takes
queen catches g3
here and then finally recaptures oh my
gosh
queen captures check takes and mates
oh man wow
guys i see all of those ideas but you
know uh rook h7 is also
just as good um it's not
you know the fancy mate that i showed
but it is a
super giga brain here so i hope you guys
enjoyed that one
um what's strange is that he's
i mean he's he's thinking about giving
up the bishop
to clear the pawn mm-hmm
let's go for it let's go for i believe i
haven't fully calculated this because i
need the time
recognizing the clock is also important
both players coming up on
like if i can't win in this position i
don't deserve tournament arc
i don't deserve to be tournament arc
champion
[Music]
and i think it's checkmates
you know those moments where you're like
if i breathe i'm going to change the
result
either you don't take with your queen
if i take your queen or it's that simple
i think
and for the first time in i don't know
how long maybe ever
esam is the one low on time
holy god damn
[Music]
this is the moment
all right this is the moment he has to
meet here figure it out
once again we are we are in the
we are in the zone where we just cannot
throw
he has bars as well rustage and uh
you know i i did a bit of uh rapping and
poetry
in uh in high school as well
i got some bars although they won't be
exposed here but
definitely got some bars fine let's
let's trade
and put them back a natural move and
then
i guess the natural recapture with the
rook
[Music]
oh it feels feels bad man i had checked
mate did i
did i have checkmate i don't know
let's just let's just let's just let's
just take his pieces for now
good call
if you can't work it out and you're low
on time
we always say just go for a plan that
you know is simple enough to work
right i think it's over
what arnisam you played really really
well today
you played really really well but
wasn't meant to be it wasn't meant to be
the protagonist rises again
[Music]
the protagonist rises once again
come
[Music]
it's over gigguk retains the title
he is the tournament arc champion
again let's listen in one more time here
[Music]
thank you very much for tuning in to
another tournament talk to you
i'll see you all next time
what a way to slide off wow that's it
the tournament arc is over gigguk wins
he is the champion
jt what can you say about that that last
game
this whole tournament everything i mean
okay so let's pick let's tackle the last
game the last game was
intense like there was just constant
attacking and it was
just one mistake you're letting you know
the bishop attack your knight
and with that pin and you you know he
followed up with pp on the pp
and he just made it work he just made it
work
and it it was a tough position it was a
position to hold because the king side
was broken but eastended
his very best in blocking and putting
the knight on g4 putting the rook on g3
really trying to hold
and it was up to giga to find all the
right moves and he did
um so it was great play from both of
them you know
it's i i can't wait to see a redemption
match between esam and geek because
honestly that
he sam played great chess throughout the
whole tournament
it was amazing chess
and wow uh i'm really
proud of um of the way he said played
he's
wow it's just so amazing um but i i talk
so yeah i'll take some credit thanks bye
cool well also take a break to fix my
camera and we'll be right back with the
players
see you in a sec y'all
[Music]
so
you
[Music]
all right and we are here with uh the
players
e sam takes second place and gigguk you
retained your title
as tournament art champion once again i
will say today's is connor's birthday so
it was meant to be his redemption arc
but i got the dub for uconn i
avenged you in true fashion um
you you it's it's now set the stage for
him to take tournament three
he's just playing he's just playing the
long game but uh yeah
i mean i'm i'm obviously happy to have
another win
um this one was i i'd even say a lot
harder than the previous tournament arc
because
i feel like last time i only had to play
really really well against the last game
against conor
i needed to be on my a game for so many
matches and so many games and so many
games came down to the wire
um it was it was tense and i can't wait
for like what what comes next basically
yeah
and uh before we get into all that jt
really i think we'd love to look at that
situation with the players now in that
last game that
all this all these ideas here so you
want to take us through some of that
there was so much sure uh so there was
um
on queen to f1
on stream i was like i hope that he
exceeds this because it's an amazing
tactic
and here you played rook g to h7 which
is a great move
i'm discounting that but there's an even
better move bishop to g1
and everything starts undefending and
the queen takes
queen takes rook takes rook takes me
oh i i want my movement
yeah i did not i did i mean like i kind
of knew
that there must have been a checkmate
pattern somewhere here somewhere
um i just unfortunately i just couldn't
see it because
uh it was it was a high pressure game
and i've never been in this position
before
so i'm just like okay let's just let's
just play it safe and just do something
safe and uh
well take material when i can but know
that
if i have a checkmate i'll take it
because i'm really hard at seeing
checkmates if i don't have a queen on
board
so maybe one day i will sack the queen
for an epic
checkmates uh it would have been it
would have been amazing if i could have
done it in the tournament
finals for like the first time but yeah
i mean i i just i just went for the
slow and steady method and uh just
slowly basically just
kind of just knocking on the door until
he let me in
basically you kind of beat it but you
forced her and it wasn't really me
letting you in
maybe for the next lesson that we have
on stream uh for turner mark 3 we'll do
queen sacrifice checkmates
ironically like for the first couple of
moves during the attack i was fairly
comfortable and then at some point i was
like mapping out like oh i'm not gonna
like move my king back and kind of get
away from it and then i saw the fact
that the bishop on v6 was blocking my
movement so i literally couldn't move to
the left and i was like
oh i think i lose i was like i was like
i think i just lose here or i lose like
way more material and then you end up
checkmating me anyway uh like i really
wanted to
uh what i'm gonna call it uh like get my
rook into it
be able to like open up my bishop to
come backwards i mean that wouldn't have
ended up helping
based on like the lines um
but it was uh it was unfortunate
for i mean i just like blazed around in
it a little too much and
maybe i castle a little too early but i
mean castling early is normally fine
it's just then
i think the big thing was letting him
get his knight to d4
because if i push the bishop out before
that uh it wouldn't have
led to me having to take with the
g pawn yeah and then that basically
started everything
yeah because i noticed we had like the
exact same
like kind of like intro pattern or like
opening pattern
yeah and then because you castled i had
one i like i i
saw that you castled early and i knew
because of that i had
one move on you because we were both
pinning the knight to the queen
so i was like okay i've got one move on
him i can literally
get the knight to d1 because you castled
and it was only because your castle that
i was able to do that
and from there it was just a really good
position for me and
um in true like monkey brain fashion i
don't know i just like
i i'm just going all attack now and
basically
that's that's i i just tried not to give
you like a single move to breathe that's
all
the one sad thing for me like the entire
set because overall like i'm pretty
happy with how i played you played
amazing
uh i did a whatchamacallit a rustage
move
where i clicked the queen was doing
other stuff and then i clicked a
different spot
i think was when i moved my queen from
like
uh let's see if the board's backwards
from d8 to e8
randomly in the middle of my defense
which like didn't do anything and i was
just like oh
i didn't mean to do that but
it was it was still rough besides that
like i think i was already losing when i
did my analysis
it just changed my plan and my comfort
yeah yeah i mean it was
it was i i feel like it was a tough
position to be in because i
was always on the attack and um i i
think
just having it was it was the bishop and
the knight
uh on which which which uh which square
was
knight on it was it was like on a square
where you couldn't chase it off so it
was like
two really really annoying pieces that
you
couldn't chase off and that just allowed
me to get my works and my queens in
position
i kind of just as you said forced my way
in just like you
you really did yeah i was just like
screaming let me in
let me in yeah the how much am i calling
gif
we got a chance to ask esam in the
post-match interview
after the match before yours
if he had prepared uh to play you
today in the case that he defeated
restage so i want to ask you the same
question did you prepare
against esam did you look up any of his
games or anything like that or
well i'm not so much looked at his games
i've just seen that he's played the same
opening as black every time so i looked
because because
because i'd already beaten him twice
when he played the opening in our games
even though i feel like there was some
opportunity that i let him back in
so i was just i went over the openings
in my games against him just to make
sure
that that it was a bit more
um like a bit more solid uh and i feel
like he also
did different things as well uh like he
actually he didn't let me push my pawn
to h5
yeah which is which was his biggest
mistake but i also
i also like i push the pawn i comment on
which square but
i think it's a g pawn and you kind of
made it awkward anyway yeah to stop to
stop his knight
from getting in to my background which
is what he was doing in my games against
him the first time
uh and then from then on it was kind of
just uncharted territory and i look at i
looked at the analysis
and it was uh it was it was an
interesting analysis because i thought i
thought i was making good moves
i really wasn't
and i gave him chance to get back in but
i mean
the lines that he like if he had played
some of the lines
to get back into that game um he would
have been playing god mode
uh and because i i did not see some of
the lines that the
you know that the computer was saying so
um
i he would have definitely deserved to
win if he had played those lines
the computer lies to us 1100 we don't
know what we're doing
that was hard i honestly want to say
that it was um
amazing chess overall and it was just
like wow
this i i never thought i would see this
level of chess
at norman r2 and why aren't you guys
like
at the world championship like this this
was such an exciting game just
like just commenting it was great
i i still have a lot myself a long way
to go it's it's nowhere near
same way i want to be right now um but
you know hopefully i'll
i i mean i i i improved since last
tournament talk so hopefully
next tournament talk i'll be completely
unstoppable hopefully
hopefully you already won
how much how much more unstoppable do
you have to get
fast um i mean i wouldn't get on
i'm just i'm just like glad now that i
can just take my mind off chest for a
bit because that's exactly what i did in
the last one
talk what happened is i just stopped
playing just for a while and i'm just
like
you know what chess is pretty fun when
it's like zero pressure maybe i should
start playing it again and uh so i'm
probably
maybe going to do the same thing for the
next tournament talk
well esam you take second place and i
have to say
you put up not just an amazing fight in
this final battle
you put up an amazing fight with gigguk
previously in the event and you also
defeated
so many more opponents than anyone to
get to the grand final so
i think you deserve a lot of praise and
uh
you gave us uh one half of the best
final we could have possibly asked for
so thank you so much for that
thank you technically i was thinking
about the bracket uh
basically mine and gigan's like hard
matches were the same because we both
had to play sea dog
each other and then uh rustage but i had
sagem
and obviously i also had techtone which
was
very an awkward game because of the
hippo
uh but it was it was fun i'm glad that
uh all three of the like like me grand
sea dog were able to play
each other uh because that was super fun
like overall i think
those were my favorite matches uh no of
course
no offense to anyone else just it was
fun uh
that was hella difficult and as uh
gigguk or
chad is saying garnt i don't know why
they're misspelling your name on purpose
um but uh i'm going to chill from chess
for a little bit because it is so
mentally exhausting and i'm just gonna
press some buttons with pikachu and i
can chill with that
yeah i'm just gonna go back to watching
anime like i like i always do
and i will watch your videos like i
always do oh thank you very much i i'm
now i want to see you play some smash
honestly it's uh maybe you can teach me
smash
i i i absolutely suck
i get trounced and smash every time so
maybe i could leave with some points on
smash
i'm down well we got each other's
discord so yeah yeah i'm on them down
i think everybody's talking smash
everybody wants to see this
i want to see some more anime like anime
and smash i actually got this just in
case we got into the second match but
we didn't so the akatsuki like kind of
cool
no you've won the whole thing man uh and
are you gonna defend your title again if
we have a tournament r3
of course of course the the protagonist
will always have to return i'm not even
sure if i am the protagonist anymore
i think i've kind of involved into maybe
the anti-hero in this one
who knows even i don't even know the i
guess the community will decide what my
role for the next one will be
um but yeah of course i'll be back to
defend once again
and i hope to challenge you yeah i'm i'm
up for i
this was like now this over i'm just
like that was so much fun
not fun what i was playing but it was
so fun looking back on it now there's
definitely a lot of um like feelings
like after a tournament because i mean
i've gotten second
at plenty of majors and i'm just like
you know even though i got second i
think overall that was very fun and cool
wish i won
but that was fun uh and this is the same
it was it was the friends we made along
the way come on that's that's what we're
doing
guys bring it back
we made new nakhma today well jt
any parting thoughts for for the for the
players before we let them go
um yeah
i want to join i want to play smash with
you guys i love playing
yeah so the connection is going to be
awful oh god
me me versus let's go over to east ham
this is starting to sound like the
beginnings of a tournament
just putting that out there i will never
trust nintendo's net code
with usa to japan it is not the same as
chess
that is not possible so we did not even
do it in japan
find me out it bass basia
i don't think latency matters so much in
chess definitely matches in smash though
all right well you heard it here guys um
and once again thank you to both of you
for giving us the event that we
absolutely wanted
uh we will maybe see you guys again next
season
and uh congratulations to both of you
thank you
thank you pleasure uh being here
pleasure being here too
bye guys and that's it
tournament arc 2 is
done gigguk wins uh
and man i mean we had so many people
rooting for so many different story
lines uh
we had the gigguk fans the returning
champion we had the redemption arc folks
rooting for connor
we had the fgc folks hopes riding on
esam as he continued through the
tournament um
oh my gosh and then of course there's
ollie right can't forget about crazy
ollie
uh bringing a massive uh
what would you a horde of zombie fans
with her creating some serious hype in
the event i mean
we had characters we had craziness
and uh we had some of the best matches
we could have asked for jt
like what is your summary of the event
it was probably one of the best of chess
events that i've ever
seen ever this is probably the most
hypest the most dramatic
the best played event that i have ever
witnessed
and all i want to ask you is what is
corner mark 3
uh i can hit him on the spot guys
neither confirm nor deny that
information
uh we'll see you know what actually i
think it's up to the fans
ultimately you guys have to tell us um
whether you think tournament arc 3 is
something that you just need in your
future
and maybe the best way to do that is to
hit us up on twitter
you can tag me or jt or even chess.com
chesscom and let them know if
you enjoyed tournament r2 and you want
to see another season
um i know i do i'm sure jt does the
other players do
and i dude we're we're at the point now
where we have to say
the last bit that we're gonna get to say
to everyone
before i don't know what for the after
party but before that let's
let's uh let's say what we want to say
jt
what i want to say to you is uh there
are only a few people
that i would have just not done this
without
right obviously sea dog and gig have to
come back
right for there to even be a story line
that
is worthy of a tournament r2 um but i
also dude would not have done this
without you
seriously this event would just not be
what it is
without your presence your amazing
commentary uh
your jokes your character your anime and
your japanese so
uh seriously dude i i owe you so much
for
for being my partner in all this
um wow um
so basically it's all me no i'm kidding
no i really like enjoy
commentating with you it's so great you
do all the production and it's seamless
you're doing commentary and production
guys like don't get it so that he's
doing
everything here i'm just looking i'm
just sitting here looking pretty and
he's just like
he's making the magic happen uh on top
of that
you know thank you to everybody who made
this happen here at chess.com and all
the contestants thank you
so much for giving us your time and
meeting with us and just interacting
with us
you definitely are part of the chess
community and just remember that i
hope to see you playing chess and if you
ever anything chess wise or anything a
friend
i'm one discord message away thank you
to all the fans who followed us
who were in the chat who were just you
know kept winging all the time thank you
so much
to everyone that you told and everybody
who just followed on twitter and
just everybody who made this possible
and
kind of like helps us get another
tournament
you know down the line right yep yeah
we'll see
yeah so again thank you to everybody
thank you to my partner jt
to the players to the chess.com staff
to the mods uh to danny wrench for
saying yes to the prize fund and uh of
course to you
the fans for uh keeping the hype going
on social media
being in the chat watching the event
rooting for your favorite players and um
and yeah i don't know what else to say
except thank you so much
for uh for everything and uh that's it
tournament arc 2 is done and uh we'll
see you around guys thank you so much
and uh have a good night i'll see you at
the after party guys take care
have some more drama over there
so
[Music]
huh
you